die friedens größe aus moskau gesendet
am dienstag zum besuch des deutschen
kanzlers kohl nichts wert der
angekündigte abzug von russischen
truppen an der ukrainischen grenze
fehlanzeige im gegenteil die nato sieht
die russen sogar bereit zum angriff
russland verlangt dass alle
amerikanischen soldaten aus mittel und
osteuropa abziehen kalter machtpoker
oder hat die diplomatie jetzt doch noch
eine chance zwischen zweifel und
zuversicht putin und der westen unser
thema jetzt in der frühlings konnte
[Musik]
phoenix runde
wir haben allen grund zur annahme dass
die einkäufer für einen in berlin haben
nicht
alle informationen die hier haben ist
dass sie bereit und die ukraine
anzugreifen so weit also der
amerikanische präsident beiden heute
entspannung sieht anders aus sprechen
wir darüber mit diesen gästen ihnen ein
herzliches willkommen hier aus berlin
und das sind meine gäste frank elbe
botschafter ag zu zeiten des kalten
krieges war er aktiv im auswärtigen amt
unter anderem holz büroleiter von hans
dietrich genscher herzlich willkommen
und ich begrüße rolf-dieter krause
langjähriger leiter des ard europa
studios in brüssel zugeschaltet ist uns
wohl japan schewski er ist deutschland
korrespondent des wall street journals
sieht also die amerikanische perspektive
er hat aber auch als europa
korrespondent für die sunday times in
brüssel und wien gearbeitet auch aus der
ost ukraine berichtet unter anderem über
die russische einflussnahme in europa
und in kiew ist uns zugeschaltet rebecca
bat sie arbeitet dort als freie
journalistin und dann sie direkt auch
die erste frage frau bat man fragt sich
ja hier wie leben die menschen in kiew
mit dieser ständigen drohung des krieges
wir haben es diese woche erlebt erst
hieß es am mittwoch steht könnte ein
einmarsch bevorstehen dann gab es
irgendwie entwarnung als bundeskanzler
scholz da war jetzt sagt präsident biden
das sieht so aus als gäbe es da bald
einen einmarsch wie erleben die menschen
in kiew dass
es ist eine sehr anstrengende woche
gewesen vor allem die letzte woche
angefangen am freitag als die eu zuerst
verkündet hat dass alle ausländischen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter das
land verlassen müssen und seitdem
befinden sich die menschen in einer
emotionalen achterbahnfahrt
ich sehe hier vor ort verschiedene
redaktionen wir haben einige menschen
die schon geraume zeit eine art notfall
koffer gepackt haben die schon seit
mitte januar praktisch bereit sind
tatsächlich ihre heimatstädte zu
verlassen und zu fliehen gleichzeitig
wächst auch ein widerstand aktuell sind
57 prozent der
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer bereits
wieder stand zu leistenden einer oder
der anderen form also einmal mit der
waffe in der hand tatsächlich über 30
die wirklich kämpfen würden andere die
an demonstrationen teilnehmen würden
oder auf irgendeine andere art und weise
widerstand leisten würden aber natürlich
haben ganz viele menschen angst sie sind
sehr verunsichert und es ist eben genau
diese informationspolitik zwischen
morgen in version dann doch nicht der
ukrainische präsident versucht zu
beruhigen die amerikanischen
geheimdienste geben praktisch invasions
pläne vor ich habe menschen getroffen
die müssen mittlerweile
beruhigungstabletten nehmen andere
gucken gar keine nachrichten mehr weil
es wirklich so auf die psyche geht es
ist schon eine sehr angespannte
situation hier vor ort und vertraut man
dann den amerikanern also so eine
aussage heute vom amerikanischen
präsidenten ist das etwas was dann
wieder gerade für besondere aufregung
gesorgt
ich habe das gefühl hier vor ort
die diese nachrichten die teilweise kam
dass auch kiew die hauptstadt mit
ungefähr fünf millionen einwohnern
angegriffen werden soll haben hier sehr
wenig menschen also vor allem
militärexperten oder sicherheitsexperten
nicht geglaubt also natürlich
verunsichert dass vor allem im kontext
eben dass viele ausländer das land
verlassen oder in gesagt wird verlasst
besser die ukraine es gibt einem schon
zu den aber in medien in politik und
eben von von solchen analysen war
eigentlich immer eigentlich ein anderes
bild gezeichnet worden und es kommt dann
immer sehr darauf an wie sehr sich eine
person informiert wem sie glaubten dem
nicht aber ich glaube habe den eindruck
dass die ukrainische regierung hier in
den letzten tagen eigentlich wirklich
gute arbeit geleistet hat zumindest
versucht hat die menschen zu beruhigen
ok schauen wir mal auf die amerikanische
perspektive japan schewski sie arbeitet
das wall street journal jetzt haben wir
heute diese ankündigung von präsident
beiden gehört erklären sie es uns ein
bisschen es gibt es also was die basis
dieser aussage oder was es ist das
interesse dahinter eine solche aussage
zu treffen
es ist wirklich schwer zu sagen was die
basis für die aussage ist also die die
die aussage in den letzten tagen auf
auf geheimdienstinformationen
dessen teilweise auch
den europäischen partner dargestellt
worden es ist natürlich immer schwierig
solche beweise zu interpretieren und die
tatsache ist dass russland die truppen
an der grenze hat die anzahl ist dass
die amerikanische regierung
glaubt dass russland jetzt die
möglichkeit hätte
ukraine wirklich anzugreifen auch von
und zwar aus von von vielen zeiten also
nicht das ist eine umfassende invasion
geben könnte
technisch ist das möglich
natürlich wie die hauptfrage ist wird
man das überhaupt was letztlich
strategie da intel und das kann nur ein
mann glaube ich eine antwort in dem camp
in das ist der ist länger tot und ich
glaube kein mensch in washington hat
wirklich eine ahnung von dem was herr
putin sich vorgestellt hat
die lage einzuschätzen wie die beweise
da das die wirklichkeit gibt
es natürlich schwer wie man damit umgeht
heraus es gab eben dieses hin und her in
dieser woche man hat er so ein bisschen
das gefühl dass es sich ein bisschen
entspannt als bundeskanzler scholz da
war was kann man eigentlich glauben
nicht
dass das ist ja das problem ich meine
die amerikanischen geheimdienste sind
haben auch schon gelogen in der
vergangenheit aber
russland lügt andauernd dass russland
ist eine einzige lüge
und deswegen muss man sich an die
unbestreitbaren fakten halten es stehen
keine nato truppen an der grenze
russlands sondern stehen russische
truppen an der grenze der ukraine
sie können angreifen ob sie es tun nur
nicht das wissen nicht das werden wir
sehen aber sie stehen da sie bedrohen
die ukraine es gibt ein einziges land
das in europa nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
mit waffengewalt grenzen verschoben hat
das ist russland kein anderes land hat
das getan das heißt viele dinge die wir
früher mal für selbstverständlich
gehalten haben das sind noch viel mehr
die sowjetunion war war das völkerrecht
angeht sehr viel genauer als die als das
heutige russland aber zum beispiel
denken sie mal an man hat immer gesagt
die rüssel kosten sind zuverlässige
lieferanten von gas sind sie nicht mehr
das ist doch kein zufall dass die
gasspeicher die das kommt bei uns
betreibt leer sind oder nicht sehr gut
ein viertel eingefärbt weil nur so
können wir kann man das als druckmittel
einsetzen und dieses gilt für viele
andere sachen und das heißt man muss
sich auf eine sehr sehr ernste lage
gefasst machen weil die fakten dafür
sprechen und das ganze klingeling da
drum herum was da wer wie will und und
und und oder nicht will
das ist viel propaganda getöse und und
da sind die russen meister darin aber
es ist nicht von mir dass
das von einem russischen schriftsteller
boris schumann ski die größte hat gesagt
die größte schwierigkeit im umgang mit
russland besteht wohl darin dass ist
liegt und das ist
ja und das ist im internationalen
verkehr ich habe mal gelernt dass sich
das dass das diplomaten
sehr geschickt sei es aber am ende muss
man sich im internationalen verkehr die
wahrheit sagen man muss sagen was man
denkt würde ich das nicht mehr tut und
wenn das unsicher wird dann sind halt
auch verträge nicht mehr
herr putin verlangt garantien der der
hat selbst die garantien gerade wir
haben ja einen einreiht gedienten
diplomaten hier amt ist der dass dieses
diese arbeit natürlich sehr aus dem
effeff beherrscht und ausüben konnte
herr
ist das denken was wir da jetzt sehen
von putin ist das sozusagen auch ein
verharren so wie es in der sowjetunion
war also das denken des kalten krieges
sozusagen
sehen sie das wieder
nein dass ich nicht wieder das ist ein
anderes denken das ist im grunde
genommen geht es ja um einen konflikt
an dem wir nicht teilnehmen der uns aber
berührt und für den wir mit haften es
geht um eine auseinandersetzung
politischer art zwischen den usa und
russland und dabei geht es um nichts
anderes als dass die eine seite ihren
einfluss ihre einflussnahme
verstärken will auf das was auf den
eurasischen kontinent passiert und eine
andere partei will vermeiden dass dieser
einfluss zunimmt ist
eine auseinandersetzung zwischen
russland und der nato und wir sind teil
der nato das ist keine
auseinandersetzung zwischen russland und
der nato denn die nato ist keine eigene
politische persönlichkeit das muss man
mal sehen aber wird von russland als
bedrohung immer genannt das hat das
gehört zum handwerk nicht was mich
berührt ist im grün nur etwas anders
auch mal dem sie gehört aber er kann
sich erleben um zum zweiten mal in
meinem leben den kalten krieg und
zwar
wie ich ihn früher auch erlebt habe die
auseinandersetzung
so heftig war sie erinnern sich noch an
richard löwenthal und im schwarzen kanal
so ist sie heute auch heftig stadt um
eine lösung bemüht zu sein versuchen wir
lager zu bilden wir teilen die welt im
eigenen land auf in transatlantiker und
putin listen und bedienen uns der
annahmen die uns von geheimdiensten
vorgegeben werden das ist keine
besonnene politik und das berührt mich
so wirklich in der tiefe meines herzens
ich habe da sorgen ich habe das anders
kennengelernt
der anderen seite wenn sie das sagen
hätte man braucht härte ich stimmte nein
ich glaube dass er immer recht hat dass
es gibt einen künftigen zwischen den usa
und russland die einen wollen die russen
aus europa heraus halten die anderen
wollen die amerikaner aus europa heraus
halten beides ist glaube ich falsch
wir wollen die amerikaner in europa
beiden das ist unser gutes recht und wir
wissen gleichzeitig dass eine friedens
eine stabile friedensordnung in europa
ohne russland nicht machen weil es nur
die frage ist ist sie mit putin
überhaupt möglich ich meine was machen
sie mit einem der sie dauernd anlügt und
der immer wieder lügt und damit
durchkommt der der mit seiner propaganda
maschine zum beispiel dafür sorgt dass
die die mehrheit der russen glaubt zur
zeit dass all diese spannung da rund um
die ukraine vom westen aus angerichtet
worden sind was schlichtweg falsch ist
niemand niemand ist den russen aggressiv
gegenüber getreten und und die
gemeinsame grenze die die naht also auch
dieses ist diese komische entwicklungs
argument fünf nato-länder haben minimale
gemeinsame grenze mit russland norwegen
die baltischen länder und ein bisschen
polen durch den bezug von kaliningrad
das ist es sechs prozent der russischen
grenze
grenzen an nato anrainer das kann man
doch nicht als umzingelt wird zahlen
trotzdem ist es ja wird das ja immer das
angemessen die original studieren frau
bat dazu mal fragen was dieses argument
dass russland sich bedroht fühlt auch
durch die ukraine erklären sie uns das
wie kommt das zustande ist das nur ein
ja ein ein argument als als vorwand um
macht auszuüben oder ist das etwas weil
es ja natürlich auch russen gibt die in
der ukraine leben also wie wird es dort
wahrgenommen
ich kann ihnen nicht erklären warum sich
russland von der ukraine bedroht fühlt
ich kann ihnen aber ganz klar sagen dass
sich die ukraine von russland bedroht
fühlt und dass vor allem derzeit mit
gutem grund ich möchte gerne noch mal
vielleicht einen schritt zurückgehen
herr elber hat eben gesagt erlebt das
zweite mal ein kalten krieg und das ist
schlimm ich bin noch keine 30 jahre alt
ich erlebe diesen zustand das erste mal
das ist auch nicht schön ich möchte aber
darauf hinweisen dass die ukraine seit
acht jahren einen heißen krieg erlebt
und das ist noch viel schlimmer seit
acht jahren herrscht in diesem land
krieg mit mal mehr und mal weniger
heißen phasen 14.000 menschen sind
gestorben und das jahr 2014 als dieser
krieg angefangen hat war für die
ukrainische gesellschaft traumatisierend
und ich finde es schade dass wir häufig
in der debatte über und um diesen
konflikt diese perspektive die
ukrainische perspektive kaum sehen wir
sind sehr schnell dabei die frage
aufzumachen nato osterweiterung
russlands sicherheitsinteressen die mit
sicherheit auch legitime punkte haben
aber die vergessen dass die ukraine auch
sicherheitsinteressen hat und die werden
seit acht jahren massiv missachtet und
deswegen ich würde gerne dass wir diese
perspektive nicht vergessen es ist jetzt
nicht das erste mal seit acht jahren das
russische soldaten an der grenze zur
ukraine stehen die stehen da seit acht
jahren jetzt sind gerade mehr aber die
stehen ja seit acht jahren tausende
oder sie wollen sie dazu verband etwas
erklären sie uns die interessen der
amerikaner an der ukraine gibt es die
überhaupt haben wenn putin ernst machen
würde sowie arbeiten dass hier heute
gesagt hat was er sich vorstellen kann
dass es bald einen angriff gibt wie
verhalten sich dann die amerikaner
das ganz genau erklärt wird zu keinem
heißen krieg kommen also die vereinigten
staaten werden nicht in das das hat er
in vorausgesagt so schon vor monaten das
ist auch gut so
es wird zu einem wirtschaftskrieg aber
kommen zumindest hat er das gedroht und
und er wird auch seine verbündeten in
europa inklusive deutschland zu drängen
das ist natürlich keine gute nachricht
weil
hinter jetzt gelage in der post
pandemische lage ersten situationen welt
gestiegen die energiepreise sind extrem
hoch schon jetzt also das wäre natürlich
sehr sehr schlecht europäische
wirtschaftsminister zukäme aber ich
glaube nicht dass darüber hinaus etwas
zu erwarten ist von den vereinigten
staaten also es gab schon einen krieg
wie die kollegen der
grund es gibt denn auch eine niedrige
intensität in horsten der ukraine und
damals hat man auch nicht wirklich
großartig reagierte gab sanktionen und
das war's dann schon und ich glaube
jetzt wird auch ähnlich sein nur die
stationen werden wahrscheinlich härter
und das ist keine gute nachricht für
deutschland tun sicher keine gute
nachricht in europa sitzt dann
letztendlich russland ja wie man immer
schon sagt am längeren hebel
weil der westen nicht bereit wäre die
ukraine zum beispiel militärisch zu
unterstützen
also auf ihn stand ich liebe so die
fragestellung nicht weil sie die dinge
vereinfacht
ich habe teilgenommen an einer
erfolgreichen politik im umgang mit
russland
wir haben eine politik der kooperation
entwickelt
sagte kurth wir eigentlich die auf dem
prinzip berühmte eine ausreichende
militärischen sicherheit auf der einen
seite und einer politik der
zusammenarbeit der vertrauensbildung der
abrüstung der anspannung auf der anderen
seite wir haben das mit einem regime
gemacht war seinerzeit eigentlich
unseren begriffen fürchterlich war wir
haben es jetzt mit einem mann zu tun der
im grunde genommen ein in russland als
einzigartig gilt als jemand der pro
westlich orientiert ist
auf der anderen seite stehen die islam
viel dass eine lange jahrhundertealte
trennung zwischen
in bezug auf den umgang mit mit tomaten
russland mit mit europa
ich persönlich bin der meinung dass wir
zwei kanzler hatten der vergangenheit da
war er gerd schröder da war auch angela
merkel die den harten ton anschlagen
würde
krause den sie gerade angeschlagen haben
indem sie sagen er ist ein notorischer
lügner frau merkel hat mir es in den
letzten wochen ihrer amtszeit eigentlich
regelmäßig mit putin telefoniert
was tut man nicht wenn man den anderen
für einen notorischen lügner hält was
wir tun müssen es gibt sogar einen
vorteil dass jemand sagt schröder und
merkel werden gut und jetzt da zu
deeskalieren
das wäre schön was wir nämlich brauchen
ist eine rückkehr zu bewährten strategie
und da sehe ich im moment keinen ansatz
und weil ich respektiere das elend und
das leid der ukrainischen bevölkerung
wir müssen ab nach vorne bringen wir
müssen weiteres schlimmeres leid für
gesamteuropa oder für lässt sich auch
für die welt verhindern wenn es wir
haben es hier zu tun mit zwei
nuklearmächten wenn die dinge eskalieren
werden sie nicht mehr zu kontrollieren
sein wir müssen zu einer zu einem
vernünftigen dialog zurückkehren und der
muss frei von beschimpfungen seien die
frage ist ob die möglich ist also
erstmal beschreibe ich nur die fakten er
hat halt gelogen und zwar wiederholt und
notorisch das fing an mit den
angeblichen ich russischen soldaten auf
der krim die dann doch russischer
soldaten waren das geht weiter mit der
behauptung in der ost ukraine stunden
keine russischen soldaten und hätten da
nie gekämpft sie haben dort gekämpft ob
es im moment auch so ist weiß ich nicht
und es geht über ex sachen weiter
wir haben in der mitte als ob jetzt
union eine andere situation gehabt weil
bestimmte prinzipien klar waren die
nachkriegs weltordnung basierte darauf
an ein ganz wichtiger punkt war die die
anerkennung der grenzen die anerkennung
der territorialen integrität die
sowjetunion selbst legte massiv wert
darauf so putin hat diese hat die
territoriale integrität der ukraine
nicht nur gebrochen sondern das muss man
sich doch mal über links das können sie
doch nicht übergehen es gab einen
vertrag das sogenannte budapester
memorandum mit dem die ukraine ihre
atomwaffen ukraine waren dass dieser
fall dass die union die drittgrößte
atommacht der welt sie hat alle ihre
atomwaffen den russen ausgehändigt und
dafür die garantie für ihre grenzen
gekriegt unter anderem eine garantie
durch russland und durch die usa und
großbritannien aber russland war
garantiemacht und hat die selbst
gegebene garantie gebrochen wie
wollen sie mit so jemandem der das macht
verträge machen wenn sie noch bei 7
heraus herr krause ich finde das sind
ja ist erstmal ist es ja so dass dass
wir anders als in der zeit die wir eben
zu recht an spricht heute keine sehr
glaubwürdige abschreckung in europa mehr
haben dass das ist das erste das zweite
ist natürlich muss mit dialog bereit
sein mit russland ist doch gar keine
frage wie niemand von uns oder im westen
will russland etwas böses das ist ein
profanes european august erreichte eine
sicherheitsgarantie
wer stellt in die sicherheit russlands
in frage keiner will russland angreifen
niemand
die nato werde die nato ein bisschen
kennt weiß dass die zu einem einem
angriffskrieg so gar nicht in der lage
ist das können die usa ja aber dass die
nato selbst kann das gar nicht und und
und und ich möchte mal wissen wie so ein
beschluss herbeigeführt werden sollte in
der nato die nato ist der ihrer natur
nach einem verteidigungsbündnis also ist
es ist greift niemand russland an und
natürlich kann man es kennt kann man
sich mit den russen über sachen
unterhalten aber es kann doch nicht
angehen dass man einem erfolg sagt ihr
dürft ihr schicksal nicht selbst
bestimmen das selbstbestimmungsrecht der
völker ist auch ein grundsatzfrage er in
unseren unter unseren internationalen
beziehungen da kann man noch nicht sagen
ich meine das hat ja putin schon
erreicht der ukraine klar zu machen dass
sie gar nicht frei agieren können frau
bat ich absagen wollten ich habe das
richtig verstanden habe ich ja ich
glaube genau das ist auch einer der
knackpunkte in diesem ganzen konflikt
der durchaus sehr komplexes und
verschiedene ebenen hat
ich habe den eindruck das von russischer
seite eben nicht gesehen wird dass das
ukrainische volk
eigenständig seinen eigenen weg wählen
möchte sondern ich habe den eindruck die
russische führung unterstellt eben dass
es durch die amerikaner induziert ist in
welche richtung sich diese gesellschaft
entwickeln möchte und das stimmt eben
nicht die ukrainische gesellschaft hat
eine eigene willensbildung und wenn das
aber nicht anerkannt wird in diesem
ganzen komplex dann wird es sehr
schwierig diesen konflikt zu lösen und
ich bin da derzeit tatsächlich sehr
pessimistisch wenn auf einer seite die
eigenständige willensbildung und die
eigenständige auch entscheidungsfindung
einer ganzen gesellschaft von über 40
millionen menschen nicht anerkannt wird
sondern man dahinter ausschließlich
amerika oder oder westliche mächte
vermutet was denken sie denn was wäre
das wichtigste was die ukraine jetzt
bräuchte zum beispiel von den
amerikanern auch
das ist eine gute frage also hier
tatsächlich sind viele menschen sehr
glücklich beispielsweise über
waffenlieferungen
ich persönlich bin mir nicht so ganz
sicher wie ich das einordnen soll ich
weit in den vergangenen wochen
beispielsweise auch in der ost ukraine
an der front habe dort recherchiert und
eben dort auch menschen getroffen die
ganz anders blicken auf diese massiven
doch waffenlieferungen die jeden tag mit
diesen waffen oder den folgen dieser
waffen leben müssen seit acht jahren und
die sagen eigentlich ist es ganz gut wie
deutschland sich verhält wir brauchen
hier nicht noch mehr waffen deswegen es
ist sehr schwierig ich glaube was die
ukraine verdient hat sind ehrliche
partner und da bin ich mir aktuell
tatsächlich nicht ganz sicher ob sie die
hat er das verlassen der ausländischen
diplomaten oder auch mitarbeiter von von
internationalen institutionen hat hier
durchaus auch den eindruck hinterlassen
dass man eben im stich gelassen wird und
dass man zu einem spielball geworden ist
dessen stimme nicht gehört wird und wenn
sich dieser eindruck verfestigen sollte
und auch bewahrheiten sollte
letztendlich und diese befürchtung habe
ich tatsächlich gerade dann glaube ich
dass uns das allen in einigen jahren
noch wirklich negativ auf die füße
fallen kann und dementsprechend wünsche
ich der ukraine einfach ehrlichkeit
tatsächlich gerade japan jesse was
denken sie in wievielen liegt der den
amerikanern an der ukraine oder geht es
tatsächlich um ja um das kräftemessen um
den machtpoker mit mit russland
zwei dinge anmerken also
ganz klar
bezüglich ukraine einen aufsatz
geschrieben
unüblich ist ein staatsoberhaupt im juli
dieses jahres hat er das auch webseite
des kreml ist und daher dass die trainer
mussten die wähler russen ein volk sind
und dass er diese diese unterschiede
nicht erkennt ist deutlich gesprochen
gesprochen und wochen später gesprochen
also da hat er schon eine sehr
differenzierte meinung geholfen das muss
man sich natürlich anschauen wenn man
dann überlegt was er was er tatsächlich
glaubt
und bezüglich diese debatte also das was
was wollen die amerikaner ist
die vereinigten staaten unterstützen
dass das recht ukraine
sich selbst hinrichs entscheiden und
nato anzunehmen der eu anzunähern und so
weiter und so fort was ich hier sehe ist
ein unterschied zwischen dem ansatz in
den washington und den ansatz in
gewissen europäischen hauptstädten in
berlin
wo dieser wille nicht so sehr hasst das
sind die leute also die politiker die
entscheidungsträger sind hier ein
bisschen
vorsichtiger also die die haben nicht
unbedingt diesen starken willen europa
ukraine an an sich anzubinden es ist
anders in warschau ist es handels im
wald kommend sagen wir es auf anderen
daten das sind die die politiker eher
denken ja ja ähnlich wie die amerikaner
aber sie in europa gibt es auch diese
spaltung des risiko genommen teil denken
und es ist schon kompliziert in dem
sinne ist ukraine
einem und vorhatten vorhalt
zustand wo sie mit mit russland leben
wollen müssen und mit mit dieser
europäische teilung leben sind und mit
der unterstützung von amerika leben
müssen wie
letztendlich nicht so weit greifen wir
das in einen krieg verhindern kann das
wäre dann eine perspektive wenn wir mal
versuchen nach vorne zu schauen wenn wir
jetzt sehen wie festgefahren das alles
ist herr krause sagt man kann putin
nicht trauen weil er liegt aber wir
müssen ja trotzdem mit dem mit dem reden
wenn sie jetzt noch im amt wären als
diplomat was wäre eine gute möglichkeit
es gibt in der fabelhaften nur logisch
dann kurz vor dem ausbruch einer
nuklearen auseinandersetzung in der
krise die den schlaf redeten kennedy ein
luke lee mit nuklearen mittel die
raketen die russland stationiert hatte
auf kuba anzugreifen
mit der folge einer massiven vergeltung
und es ist doch ein zufall verhindert
worden als er nachfragte was passiert
denn dann wenn das eintritt und dann
sagte der chef der joint chiefs of staff
ja wir rechnen mit 80 millionen toten
dann sagte kennedy laut vor sich hin
denkend 80 millionen sowjet menschen ein
sagte der amerikanische general
amerikaner in dem moment war das
gespräch mit den mit den generellen
beenden und dann tat kennedy das was ich
jetzt auch empfehle er griff zum
telefonhörer und sprach mit christoph
und dieser dialog in dem wir erfahrung
haben anders als die amerikaner und die
engländer und die polin der muss jetzt
wieder aufgenommen werden aber am
dienstag hat der bundeskanzler vier
stunden mit herrn putin gesprochen es
ist ja nicht so dass es keinen dialog
gibt
ja und der bundeskanzlerin steht vor
einer begleitmusik die in deutschland im
grunde genommen sehr sehr kompliziert
ist
putin will auch gar nicht mit
deutschland oder österreich lebende
wirth mit den usa einverstanden sind das
ist einverstanden und und der also noch
mehr gemacht alle gehabt kuba blockiert
mit einer seeblockade und und und und da
ist noch eine menge mehr passiert wird
also ich glaube schon ich glaube es ist
die mischung von beidem natürlich also
food ihn ist der russische präsident
also muss man mit ihm reden auch wenn
man oft monologen wurde ist auch gar
kein geht doch gar nicht anders aber die
frage ist ob wir das nicht mit auch
positionen verbinden müssen wo wir auch
härte zeigen und meinen wir reden dann
immer über diese pipeline als ob das die
einzige möglichkeit einer sanktion wäre
es gibt auch andere
lassen wir doch mal die fantasie spielen
also die ganze entourage von putin soll
sich im sommer sehr gern an europas
küsten
die haben immobilien in berlin in paris
in london in cannes in st tropez
mal die aufenthaltserlaubnisse für all
diese menschen so das ist das ist dir
das sind direkt die leute auf die sich
putin stützt und und die von seinem
system profitieren so und und und da
muss man gar nicht andere sachen machen
und diese und sagen wir können auch
anders
ich finde der die entspannungs politik
der der 70er jahre 1660 antwort und der
70er jahre war möglich weil es auf der
einen seite eine sehr feste wester
westliche haltung gab
verbunden mit dem gesprächsangebot zu
sprechen interessenausgleich zu machen
und und ich sage das war eine der
letzten tage ein teil der westen geeint
war er
die führung war auch deutlicher aber der
aber aber man hatte auch umgekehrt in
der sowjetunion ein gesprächspartner der
er sich an verabredungen gehalten hat
immer so was wie die schlussakte der
konferenz über sicherheit und
zusammenarbeit in europa das war ein
hoch kompliziertes gebilde kam nicht
ganz leicht zu stande und als es dann
stand war das hier für die verdient für
die länder des warschauer pakts auch
nicht immer einfach sich daran zu halten
was menschenrechte angeht usw es hat
aber funktioniert weil sie alle gewillt
waren sich an die sachen zu halten so
und natürlich kann man den russen zu
sagen die amerikaner wollen die ukraine
dann land in der nato die europäer nicht
und das ist eigentlich ausgeschlossen
gewesen dass es gab ein nato gipfel in
bukarest vor vielen vielen jahren und da
hat man gesagt im prinzip kann die
ukraine beitreten aber es steht nicht an
und ich kenne niemanden in europa und
dafür wird die aufnahme sind alle
erforderlich der im moment oder in dem
vor zwei jahren oder vor fünf jahren die
ukraine hätte aufnehmen wollen und bei
so weit
der wunsch der ukraine in die nato zu
gehen wäre nicht so ausgeprägt wenn die
ukraine nicht bedroht würde dass das
wären dann vermutlich kurz dazu möchte
ich dir sagen
wir haben die wiedervereinigung
abgeschlossen mit einem weiteren großen
recht sein das war die charta von paris
die eine entscheidung zwischen allen
beteiligten vor
die amerikaner waren damals bereits
second amt zu sein niemanden überlegen
und niemanden unterliegen und das
änderte sich mit dem präsidentenwechsel
die amerikaner haben heute eine andere
politik gegenüber russland und unter
umständen müssen wir auch mal mit
unseren amerikanischen freunden reden
denn wir laufen die gefahr
dass wir die zuneigung und den respekt
des russischen volkes und der rutsch in
münchen verlieren und das muss man auch
mal berücksichtigen die der politik die
wir zurzeit machen also mehr respekt
wenn sie da fordert
er mehr dialog frau bat welche
perspektive bräuchte die ukraine hätte
sie gerne
wenn man sich umfragen in der
bevölkerung derzeit anguckt dann ist es
natürlich ein nato-beitritt und ein
eu-beitritt ich persönlich frage mich
jedoch ob diese debatte nicht mehr eine
scheindebatte ist denn
der nato beitritt steht überhaupt nicht
an erstand nie an in den in den letzten
jahren es gibt heute hat sie längst
gesicht noch gegenüber der bild zeitung
dahingehend geäußert dass ihn sehr
bewusst ist dass es nato staaten gibt
die die ukraine nicht in der nato haben
möchten und außerdem erfüllt sie auch
nicht die voraussetzungen und sie wird
sie auch in den nächsten jahren nicht
erfüllen deswegen kann ich es immer
nicht so ganz nachvollziehen warum wir
uns so sehr auf diese debatte versteifen
ich habe eher den eindruck dass jedoch
auch künstlich herbeigeführt wurde eben
von der russischen führung
klar möchten dass die ukraine aber wie
eben schon richtig gesagt worden ist ist
das eine folge des krieges ist eine
folge der aggression von seiten
russlands
ich würde gerne darüber reden was kann
russland denn auch tun um diese um ein
bisschen zu deeskalieren
was kann russland in der ukraine
anbieten warum sprechen wir darüber
nicht russland hält sich seit acht
jahren aggressiv gegen ein land das sie
nichts getan weil man es nicht denkt
also das tun würde dass das land das wir
um eigentlich gehört die eskalieren
können wie wir einen schritt auf
russland zu machen können russland muss
auch einen schritt auf die ukraine zu
machen wenn russland das tut ist ja gar
nicht so das scheint nun alles andere
als möglich zu sein im moment
hermannstadt würden sie sagen was würden
wir das erwarten die amerikaner von den
europäern und auch vielleicht von
deutschland in diesem konflikt gibt es
da so was dass man sagt okay die könnten
da auch eben mithelfen dass dieser
konflikt nicht weiter eskaliert
naja ich denke da gibt es zwei schienen
der verhandlungen momentan die eine geht
durch washington und den präsidenten
beide und die andere ließen und berlin
verhandeln
amerikaner und die koordinieren sich
miteinander
im fall des falles erwarten natürlich
die amerikaner dass die sanktionen so
hart werden dass das die auch wehtun und
in dem
konkrete deutschland hieße das natürlich
ist 19 2 dann auf eis gelegten muss oder
oder gar unter sanktionen gestellt
werden muss der hält sich dazu noch
nicht geäußert
der hat die hörten sm2 noch nicht
verwenden weil diesen ganzen
pressekonferenz
er sagt ja immer wir werden sie wissen
was dann zu tun ist aber ich wollte noch
etwas anmerken zu der zu den vorherigen
hatte die freundin von airbus angestoßen
war ich glaube zurzeit ist ist kommt die
gefahr für die jetzt gerade aus
vielleicht aus der schwäche der
beteiligten weil in den kalten krieges
gab es eine gewisse stärke und eine
gewisse symmetrie und jetzt sehen wir
dass das heer präsident putin vielleicht
aus aus aus der schwäche heraus handelt
ja der ja versucht ja die erosion seine
macht und seines einflusses zu begrenzen
der hat ja ukraine verloren und der
werft sucht die trainerin mit zurück zu
ziehen in die in den russischen
einflusssphäre
dagegen steht daher beim seine umfragen
sind nicht nicht so toll im kongress ist
die lage auch nicht ganz vor vorteilhaft
für ihn und der ist wahrhaftig kein
rundes regen im sinne von von dieser
halte stärke die
bisher besaß und dann davor war der herr
kramp also wir wissen alle wie geht es
denn schafft geändert hat mit diesen
zahlen die dann ins parlament
eingebrochen sind also die die lage ist
relativ unübersichtlich dass das lässt
sich nicht mit dem kadett krieg
vergleichen dann gab es eine gewisse
stabilität bekommst du auch die verträge
die
glaube ich wen hat jetzt gibt es die
verträge nicht es gibt die die
machtverhältnisse nicht mehr und um die
balance ist ist auch schon recht ich
mich sowieso
noch ein problem mit den russen zu
folgen die eben auch dann auf gegründet
worden sind der elbe wenn man das jetzt
anschaut wie kommt man da wieder raus
ist wenn er einen einen menschen putin
der natürlich kein gesicht wahren will
denn natürlich
maximalforderungen jetzt gestellt hat
wie kriegt man das hin dass er ja sich
irgendwie bewegt in richtung des westens
in richtung deeskalation und es dann so
zu schaffen dass er sein gesicht wahren
kann und das ist so jemandem
wahrscheinlich wichtig
also ich würde die these widersprechen
dass putin aus einer schwächer situation
heraus handelt
und würde das mit der demonstration
seiner stärke an der grenze nicht machen
ich glaube es gibt eine überlegung die
auch die amerikaner
beobachtet haben
deswegen fühlen sie auch parallel
gespräche zu nuklearen fragen es scheint
so als ob die russen im besitz einer
militärischen technologie sind die was
den einsatz nuklearer mittel angeht ein
stück überlegenheit gegenüber den
amerikanern und ich finde es merkwürdig
finde es fast auch beruhigend das ist
diesen dialog gibt
der so ganz anders verläuft
auf der ebene der fachleute frau
victoria nuland
blinken und vertreter dass das
vertreter des state department des
außenministeriums da sehe ich auch einen
ansatzpunkt der hoffnung dass wir werden
das wahrscheinlich sehen entweder wir
haben in der nächsten woche den
verkündeten von an beiden angekündigten
krieg oder wir haben weitere vertiefte
gespräche der amerikaner und großen über
sicherheitskontrolle und dann kann es
einen neuen anfang geben daran glaube
ich
jetzt beginnt er in münchen die
sicherheitskonferenz oder schauen immer
viele drauf und da treffen sich nun
viele viele amerikaner sind da in
münchen und ganz wenig russen und
eigentlich keine große studierte
negation die etwas bewegen könnte ist
das ein punkt wo man sagt da haben wir
das tun wir auch eine chance diese
formate sind eigentlich wirklich
hilfreich um auf der großen bühne der
weiterzukommen ich weiß nicht ob wir
diese chance vertun ich weiß nicht warum
die russen nicht da also und ich nehme
nicht an dass sie nicht eingeladen
gewesen sind sondern sondern ich bin bin
ziemlich sicher dass herr ischinger
der chef dieser sicherheitskonferenz sie
eingeladen haben wird gibt es eine
erklärung
also der teltschik hat sich sehr
deutlich in einem interview gegenüber
der deutschen welle geäußert zu der
einladung die jahr 2008 ausgesprochen
hat an putin und putin hat ihm gesagt
ich komme gerne und dann hat putin
gesprochen und hat beschwerdepunkte
vorgetragen und die erste reaktion die
von seiten der journalisten kamen war
die von herrn hoppe von der zeit der
keinen beitrag lieferte sondern eine
feststellung herr putin sie reden mit
der sprachen der sprache des kalten
krieges am nächsten tag schrieben alle
deutschen zeitungen putin kehrt zum
kalten krieg sei das das schreckt
natürlich einen russen ab wenn er auf
diese art und weise vorgeführt
also ich meine sie trotzdem so leute wie
labors oder so die hätten früher da
keine berührungsängste gehabt sondern
cool da gesessen also dass das ist ich
finde das ist bedauerlich ich glaube
dass es dass wir gut daran tun für
gesprächs formate zu sorgen dass wenn
wir sie nicht haben ich glaube dass es
verschiedene gar nicht genug foren geben
kann dafür hält und dass das aber auch
klar sein also ich finde da man muss
dann dabei auch klar sein und man muss
dann auch dinge ansprechen die sag doch
mal ist hat aus russland kein anderes
land seit dem zweiten weltkrieg in
europa grenzen mit gewalt verirren sie
sich dass der bundeskanzler zu wenig
angesprochen hat er hatte ja nicht
einmal bei der pressekonferenz das war
nicht also die ja dann nach außen hin
natürlich auch ich glaube viel wichtiger
ist das was die nicht in der
pressekonferenz miteinander besprechen
ihrem land er und und und und unter ich
hoffe dass sie da
also ich hab ja manchmal
viel zu spät meistens bei
internationalen begegnungen da gehört
was da wirklich geredet worden ist und
denn das erfährt man meist es dann drei
oder vier tage später aber der ist
eigentlich wird soll da klartext geredet
werden und ich finde da muss man da muss
man dann wirklich
den helm abnehmen und sich in die augen
gucken und sagen was man voneinander
denkt und wo man die schwierigkeiten
sieht und und da muss man nicht sofort
zueinander kommen das ist übrigens etwas
da würde ich würde aber auch zustimmen
wir haben auch probleme und vielleicht
wird das in münchen erörtert werden auch
mit unseren amerikanischen freunden
es sind die besten freunde die wir in
der welt finden können aber aber die
haben nicht immer die selben interessen
wie wir und ich meine gerade bei der
pipeline
wir wissen alle dass die amerikaner uns
gern ihr gas verkaufen haben und dass
die pipeline dabei stört und und das
macht sie nicht sehr glaubwürdig das ist
doch vollkommen klar aber das ist nicht
das einzige deswegen sage ich bei dem
ganzen wortgeklingel was es da gibt man
muss sich die fakten gucken und und und
die fakten strich mal sie sprechen im
moment nicht für die russische
opposition jetzt also ich hatte am
anfang gefragt apple ganz kurz mit der
bitte um kurze antwort in der chance für
die diplomatie die sehen sie aber noch
nicht die sich immer noch ein was die
pipeline angeht sich die aus dem grunde
weil man den menschen erklären muss wie
man
52 milliarden kubikmeter gas wir uns in
der zukunft verloren gehen weil die
ölfeld und gasfelder in der nordsee
versiegen kompensieren will ohne eine
zusammenarbeit bild russen und darin
sehe ich die chance
ganz kurze frage an frau bat wie viel
sorgen und wir versorgen schauen sie in
die nächste woche
ich schaue mir sehr große sorgen und ich
habe mir auch schon den heutigen tag mit
sehr großen sorgen angeschaut denn was
wir heute gesehen haben ist eine
eskalation eine militärische eskalation
in der ost ukraine was an der gesamten
frontlinie ist geschossen worden zwei
zivilisten wurden verletzt mindestens
zwei soldaten einen kindergarten es
getroffen worden
das stimmt nicht sonderlich
zuversichtlich ok dann hoffen wir mal
dass sie recht haben das ist eine chance
noch gibt für die diplomatie vielen dank
herr krause hält frau beate alles gute
für sie nach kiew und vielen dank und
ihnen liebe zuschauer vielen dank für
das interesse das war phoenix die runde
diese woche jetzt geht's hier weiter mit
für nix der tag bis dahin
die öffentlichkeit zu empören und den
toni zu schaffen für eine erfundene auf
einem vorrunde rechtfertigung